[Music]  earlier this week the video game Gears  of War 3 went on sale for the Xbox 360  people usually yeah they people love  this game  alright I'm going to tell you something  though the Gears of War series has  always been very violent very macho  critics though are now saying that the  latest game is surprisingly emotional  and they turn off hardcore gamers you  decide for yourself take a look at this  new version oh it's so peaceful here you  know I do most of my poetry writing in  this place I love the green poetry sure  sometimes I'd love to hold on one second  what kind of Sun hits the rock beautiful  getting in shape for the Big Dance  oh man you look great already how are  you too kind hey did you hear REM broke  up what  [Music]  the game